i can't tell you how much fun it is to
interview
someone who's been an inspiration to me
such as jordan harbinger
uh he's been podcasting for over a
decade
it's hard to believe when you look at
him he's got such a baby face but the
things you're going to learn today
really sets you off on a path to either
succeed as a podcaster
do so with authenticity or perhaps seek
out new paths in your career
in your relationships and in any other
endeavor which requires some amount of
creativity
some amount of introspection some amount
of reflection
on what it really means to be a
completely fully rounded individual and
jordan is
one of the best i know he does such deep
research from all of his guests i was
honored to be on the show a couple
months ago
and i was actually blown away he did
research that
even some of my graduate students
weren't capable of doing
and you'll hear a little bit about that
in today's interview he's
really a rising star pun intended
but the fact that he's been rising for
well over a decade tells you that he's
on a path to go somewhere extremely
special
so i hope you'll enjoy this episode
recorded over the summer
2020 and making use of probably more
time than he intended to give to me but
he's such a generous person
such an influence and i want to thank
jordan for all he's done for me
personally and all he does for
for the planet how many people can you
say that about enjoy this interview
with none other than the eponymous
jordan harbinger
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast i am your fearful
host
brian keating professor of physics at
the university of california san diego
and co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination where we run the into the
impossible podcast
the name into the impossible of course
comes from one of sir arthur c clarke's
famous three laws
of nature uh one of them being uh
the uh the any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
and my guest today uh this uh
distinguishes himself via the
impact he's made on podcasting uh not
only
taking a show basically from nothing a
self-made man
not in the robotic sense where he could
assemble himself although i'm sure he
could do that
but actually making himself over from a
lawyer
to being a law student at least then
going to forming one of the
best top ranked podcasts in the world
then uh losing that
uh as as some of us have lost other
other things in our lives uh
and then rebuilding it better than ever
a new podcast called the jordan
harbinger show
uh jordan first of all welcome how are
you doing how are you sheltering today
i'm sheltering well thank you i moved in
with my brother-in-law which is not
exactly what they had in mind with
shelter in place probably but whatever
and i'm building a house next door so
i'm building new shelter can you say
that for yourself
no you can't taking shelter in place to
a new i
am building a whole new shelter that
didn't even exist before so that's how
serious i'm taking this
and uh i just had a kid who's now 11
months old so he came into the world
and and destroyed our ability to go and
do anything just in time
for kova to come and destroy everyone's
ability to go and do anything so
it's actually prepping you it's honestly
i i hate to make light of this
but we kind of have to or we're all
going to go insane it's been quite
convenient to have a new baby
during this time because nobody can do
squat anyway so the feeling of fomo is
non-existent
yeah um that's the bright side for me
you know on this
is like you know before when he was
really young people were like hey i'm
renting a
beach house why don't you come down i'm
like i got a
three week old baby man i'm not doing
that you know and and it would be like
oh why don't you bring the baby to
taiwan
and we're like uh he's too young and
then covet hits and we're like
oh okay so even the instagramers are now
like here's my basement
you know exactly i have a rule i have a
rule that anytime you get two excuses
uh for for one reason it's it's one of
them is a lie
basically you know like oh my cat died
and there was traffic on the freeway
you know you know one of those is a lie
because one of those would be sufficient
right and so
i kind of feel like you know jaden was
already the trump card that superseded
anything your
young son and uh you didn't need the
pandemic but now you've got double the
excuses so
right no no and it's not even just the
excuse it's that like
we don't feel like other people are out
doing all this amazing stuff and we're
missing out because they're not they're
all at home and i kind of feel bad for a
lot of my friends who
they're like oh we were gonna have kids
last year but you know we decided to
wait and i'm like ooh now would have
been a great time to have an infant and
just sit at home
and you know right for the doctor's
appointments right
well even then i mean yeah you're
probably right but now
um a lot of doctors are i think doing
house calls i could because they want to
keep at least in california there's
house calls going on
with some doctors because they're like
we don't want you to come in if you're
sick like the
worst thing you can do is come in and
see the receptionist and sit in the
waiting room and then use the bathroom
yeah so around here it's actually been
quite nice
we also and i'm because i'm in silicon
valley which is actually kind of
the heart of we're like the west coast
hq of infections right now
so there's a lot of hey let's be extra
careful
um there are doctors appointments but
you'd be
i don't know why but there haven't been
that many
maybe it's because i've i have twins and
so that's like eight oh you have twice
as many
[Music]
i wanted to first uh start with
something that i always associate with
you
um which is this trait of gratitude and
i want to uh
give a shout out to uh to a mutual
friend actually i don't even know how
you guys know each other but connor
beaton
runs the man talks podcast and about two
or three years ago when my book came out
on losing the nobel prize he somehow
found me
and invited me on his show and we did my
first ever like
big time podcast you know i had done
podcasts for my own
uh but it was the first you know kind of
internet or nationally known podcast
he's a well-known guy
and we recorded it and we use the
software that i think you use you know
or maybe it's a different one
and i was like so stoked after the
podcast i just closed up the laptop i
was like all right we're done that's
whew that was that was wonderful and
then like weeks went by
and i'm like uh hey connor any word when
the podcast gonna run you know the books
out i'd love to you know have some promo
and
be great to to see it live because i had
such a good i didn't respond for a
couple of times that i emailed him
finally i was like god did i did he not
record it
is something wrong uh did did it not
work out and then i emailed him like
did you not record it or was there a
problem on mice he's like yeah
unfortunately
i hate to have to do this but we're
gonna have to do it again and i said oh
you know it's okay i mean he's so fun
and nice to talk to that i took it you
know kind of looked on the bright side
said okay it's another hour to spend
with a
super interesting guy uh and you know i
could have been like
you hey well you know you're
unprofessional how could you but you
know he's
such a great guy and it's such an
interesting show and then a couple days
later he's like sends
uh sends a a non-double opt-in email
shall we say
uh to you and copies me on it um and
tells you all the great things about me
and uh all these lies and so forth
but then he and then he you know and
then we took it from there and
it took two years eventually i got on
your show and then
eventually you helped me get on james
altucher's show
and then uh james had me uh came on my
show and we recorded a three-hour long
interview so
you know i hope you've got another three
hours to go to match up with james
altitude
uh but then you know just kind of gone
from leaps and bounds but if it hadn't
been
you know if i had kind of not taken the
bright side which you have you know
said many times that you pursue the path
of like
let me see how this could be skewed
towards the good
and i associate that trait with you and
by using this this kind of
tactic that you helped me develop to see
the gratitude in the situation of having
to record the second episode
lo and behold i've been connected to
wonderful people in an industry and and
tried to become
you know sort of a semi-professional
they'll don't tell
our governor that that's what i do but
no i'm not professional at all i don't
make any money on this but i want to
thank you for that
um uh for for kind of you know setting
these things in motion
uh for me and and being a role model not
only to me but to many people in the
podcast world and uh first thing is you
know now that you had me on the show are
you depressed because all your
you know dream guests are you know can
only let you down for me i mean
yeah i mean it has been tough but we
have figured out ways to i mean i had
ray dalio on recently so he came pretty
close to matching your performance on
the show
um you know but i always have i can
always look back on my kobe bryant
episode if i want to see somebody who's
just on par with what you deliver
that's right that's right and um you
know so
uh the one thing that i want to get into
maybe later is you know how you
how the podcast has been developed
basically from scratch
twice and um but the main thing the
first thing i want to talk about is your
unusual background i mean
you were a law student uh i don't think
you ever practiced law right
i did and i passed the bar in new york
and i'm still a lawyer but thanks for
doing your homework
no wonder you didn't get that nobel
prize there's a lot of loose ends in
this uh
prep here well the first thing i want to
ask you is you know is the reason that
you left law because you're no longer a
practicing lawyer at least
you tell me that you're not my lawyer on
every show i listen that's right i
assume you're talking to me
uh but uh but uh you know it was that
worse than living in north korea
because i understand you did live in
north korea i went to north korea four
times
i never lived there i don't think that
would have been a that would have been
quite a feat
and would have probably also been really
there's a lot i can imagine there's
limited options for dining and
other things like that that you quickly
exhaust
your resources living in a place like
that um
which is worse the law profession or
north korea
yeah i mean the work hour it depends
where you work right uh what firm you're
at
but i i didn't mind being a lawyer
it was long hours but i also worked for
a cool firm
that later went under because you know
just
we were over leveraged in 2007 big time
um so it i didn't mind being a lawyer
you know i worked with cool people i
learned a lot at the firm i just wasn't
interested in it which wasn't their
fault it wasn't like oh these people are
all jerks i can't stand them
there was nothing like that really it
was just a matter of
i never wanted to be a lawyer i went to
law school because i had a hard time
getting a job after college even though
i had a four-year degree from the
university of michigan
i spoke different languages it's just
you know
they didn't teach us how to get jobs and
i'm not blaming them
but also when you're 21 and you went to
college and you think you're supposed to
get a job after that and nobody even
shows you
step one of like how to find jobs
it gets a little hi it gets a little
crazy yeah it gets crazy
and i went to law school because i
thought well at least then i'll have a
better education and then of course
once you graduate with from a trade
school which is what law school is it's
just a really expensive
in fact quite overpriced trade school
then they recruit you
especially in a hot market so we had
this kind of
really easy going for me because i
didn't worry about it
because i didn't care where i worked
this recruiting thing where they they
took over a motel you know somewhere in
north campus and all these firms came in
and
and said okay who wants to work here
hand us your resume and if you're not a
complete a-hole
you get a second interview in new york
city you know that was like if you have
a pulse and you're not picking your nose
and wiping it on your sock during the
interview you're hired yeah kind of deal
and do you feel like uh that training
you know as as
is kind of commoditized as it is it does
teach you at least you know
from what i see on tv which is you know
of course a representation of reality
uh perhaps not but uh but you know did
that teach you because you have this
um especially acute auditory and verbal
communication ability which you know you
don't rely on video as much as other
people do
although perhaps you're gonna get more
into that i want to talk to you about
that later because um
you know there's a notion that in
psychology that the voice is actually
deeper than the eye
and that you're not supposed to rely on
eyewitness testimony and things like
that but i'm wondering
sometimes i mean you're like a super
friendly cross examiner like you really
dig
deep you do research harder than anybody
i uh
that i know i mean you found an article
about uh maria mayer who is behind me
behind me over here there she is on the
wall she's the second woman to ever win
a nobel prize in physics
and i had been told by her son at an
event in person in 2011
when they had a stamp dedicated to her
after she passed away and her son has
since passed away
he told me when she won the nobel prize
the headline in the newspaper was
san diego mother housewife wins nobel
prize
and i was like i can't i gotta find that
headline i couldn't find it
and i didn't find it until the show
notes from our episode came out and
somehow you found it so
i guess it's a long way of saying like
do these skills from law school
translate evidence searching you know
research and then also
cross-examination did they not prove
helpful to you in this career that you
have now
20 20 hindsight they did but if you'd
asked me right when i came out of law
school and into interviewing
for the jordan harbinger show if i'm
using the rules of
not really the rules of evidence but to
some degree like rules of evidence legal
research
uh principles i would be like no i'm not
using any of that crap
but but truthfully there is a notion
in me now a a
sensibility that you need to go beyond
the headline
or that certain arguments are
deliberately misleading
or just misleading maybe not even
deliberately misleading
so i typically on when i do research for
the jordan harbinger show i'll look up
an article with a perspective and that
perspective
might say something along the lines of
oh well
you know these these numbers say this
therefore
that and i'll be like well it could mean
that let's find expert testimony i don't
call it expert testimony i call it
another perspective
but that's what expert testimony really
is is like who
is writing about this that is not
writing for right wing
crazy.org you know blog
let's have them interpret these numbers
and then you'll find someone who'll go
huh okay well these numbers are true but
they that's not what this means when
this isn't the conclusion you draw from
these and then there's this other
statistic that is just complete bullcrap
that they made up and you're like oh
okay well that's good to know
and then you'll look at another blog and
another perspective or another article
and it's like
well these numbers are right and this is
the conclusion you draw from it
but the conclusion and what the author
of this piece is now saying
are actually like he's deliberately
mischaracterizing that conclusion or the
context of that conclusion
or something along those lines and that
comes from
what i learned in law school but also
turns out to be just what everyone now
has to do because we can't count on
people to give us the truth
now we're now we're looking at i now
look at media like they're advocating
for a perspective which is exactly how
you argue in a courtroom
you go well this and this and this and
this and if you take it at face value
you're in trouble because that's what
this person's lawyer is saying and
they're arguing for their client
whereas now i'm going okay well what's
the other side of this because we really
can't hear any argument until we have
the other side because
you don't you only have one version of
events yeah so what's really going on so
i take all my research and show prep for
the jordan harbinger show and i go okay
what is it exactly that we're looking at
that that is going to deliver
a conclusion here and is that conclusion
what this person wants us to see or is
this what
essentially is what is the truth how do
you balance that with you know
you don't want to entrap your your
witness host your guest rather
you know i find like yesterday i had a
gnome chomsky who's you know the world's
no big deal yeah he's just he's just the
world's most sighted intellectual in
human history
um and i disagree with a lot of his
politics and and some of his opinions
and
you're not an anarchist or whatever well
i mean he's
super far left but now he's come so far
left it's like walking around the
equator you come back to where you were
but here i am in new guinea again how
did that happen and i was thinking you
know he just had this huge thing in
harper's magazine where he co-signed
with jk rowling
and i could have like been like well how
could you do this and i know i get a lot
of clicks and i didn't do that i mean i
mentioned jk rowling
and it was actually a good opportunity
for him to say look the people that are
criticizing
me for the people who signed after me on
this letter of intellectuals
uh demonstrate their fundamental
irrational first of all the guy speaks
in complete paragraphs like structured
300 word paragraphs and he doesn't ever
say um or
because it's perfectly well formed it's
about this volume
and he's just so brilliant but i knew i
could say look you and elon musk have a
beef you know he called you an idiot he
said you're a
[ __ ] and you know i could really blow
that up but
you know and that'll be good for clicks
and clickbait and actually he would talk
about it i mean i did mention
elon musk but how do you balance that
you know because you want to be known as
you know that's some hostile prosecutor
and you're never like that but
you must have had guests besides me
where you're like this guy's full of you
know what and like i just this is this
total nonsense so how do you balance
that you know
kind of being a mensch as you are but
also kind of just going for the truth
and and and you know suppressing those
early instincts
uh well i mean i had roger stone on the
show need i'd say more
so i i mean i what i do bernie madoff
wasn't available bernie madoff was not
available
and i would definitely interview him in
a second but i'm pretty sure he's on
some kind of media blackout what do i
know
um i this is the wrong phrase to use but
i'm going to
see if i can make it work here i try to
give people
like that but yeah let me just stick
with the roger stone example i try to
give people like that enough rope
to hang themselves so to speak so i
don't go
and then you did this i'll be like and
then what happened and then why did you
do that
and then did it and then after a while
that person will get the idea that since
i'm not an unfriendly or
hostile interrogator or interrogator
or or uh counsel or a host whatever you
want to call it yeah
they'll start to go oh i'm i'm doing my
shtick when people
like me and they're entertained by what
i'm doing i'm doing that so
you know roger stone was like yeah
richard nixon this that the other thing
stone's rule number seven
always deny deny denied and he's going
through this over and over and over
and at the end he's like thanks this is
really a lot of this is great and i know
he's kind of like
cool i was on a show where this guy
totally agrees with everything i say and
it's like
then it's like the and i don't have to
end the show with like oh do you hear
all that crap this guy's terrible i
don't have to do that i just air the
show and people go
whoa that guy just showed his true
colors is that evil
or is he just insane i don't know i
don't know
and that's what you want because if i go
if i push back right away
and he goes yeah richard nick said this
but this guy did this and he disgraced
the office of the president
then what is he going to do everything
after that's going to be measured it's
going to be
clamped up it's going to be what he
thinks people want to hear but
which is going to be very vanilla
because he's not roger stone isn't good
at telling people what they want to hear
because he's himself
you know like he's a different type of
person
um for better or for worse you know and
so you have to let people if i'm gonna i
have to decide early am i gonna like
argue with this person because the
audience wants to hear my opinion on
what they're doing
and see them get pushed back on or does
the audience just want to see
this person's true personality come out
and for me i'll push back on certain
ideas or certain things
and i'll get them to explain themselves
but i'm not going to go don't you think
you're just being a totally
big bastard bad guy doing this and this
and this it's like well where what is
what is that going to get me a couple of
applauses
applauses from people sitting in there
on the car
or driving to work like who cares you
know and it will ruin you know your
biggest proponent of networking and it
might you know deny you access to
like steve cohen or somebody like that
yeah other people in the in the world
we'll see but but i want to be really
clear here my idea isn't to get
roger stone to be like that jordan guy's
really nice call me anytime jordan let's
roll up a joint you know it's not my
idea
of what i want to do on the show they're
allowed to not necessarily like me after
that but i'm not going to go out of my
way to be like
see you know you hear these political
shows like who's this
who's the guy like dan bongino bongino
yeah i can't even tell where does that
sound uh dirty but they're not yeah
yeah exactly and he's the type of guy
where he's like
and then these freaking liberal retards
you know they did it
and i'm like oh i get it you're just the
angry guy who's like the uncle at
thanksgiving that everyone hates
except for this is your whole shtick so
it's your whole show and it's popular
because there are a lot of people that
are like
oh look at him make fun of people that i
don't understand
owning the all right owning the libs man
and it's like no he's just talking to a
bunch of dummies in the garage
you and you're giggling because he's
like yeah the retards
but they're the the the people he
doesn't like are not listening to him
because he's a he's a clown
right so like that kind of yeah go ahead
what are you achieving
when you do that you're talking only to
people that agree with you so you're not
making any meaningful change
you're making things more divisive
you're literally
just a clown and and that's one of the
reasons why
i stopped watching certain shows like
i think bill maher is funny but i don't
necessarily want to watch his show
because
all the panels unless
yeah and look i have to google that word
but like unless one of my friends is on
those panels
i don't usually watch because it's just
like
oh my god and then trump did this can
you believe that oh my god well he's an
ass what a [ __ ] that guy is
yeah let's make fun of him more and i'm
like am i getting anywhere
no it's really it's just the echo
chamber right everywhere it's an echo
chamber of comedians and then there's
like an academic and then there's like
another person and they're giving
their opinion yeah and then it's like
frannie leibowitz is making fun of this
person and then
you know charlemagne the gods making fun
of this person but michael moore will
come in with uh yeah
right if charlemagne's on there i'm
going to watch but like you know yeah i
don't want to be in that echo chamber
and again i like bill maher i think he's
he can be really funny and he's like
witty and insightful
but and the other reason i stopped
watching shows like that is and here's
how you can tell right because
you watch the show and they'll get like
james comey on there and i'm like great
he's gonna interview james comey
seven minutes later he's like thanks for
coming in let's go to our panel and i'm
like what are you doing
he flew to new york or l.a sorry yeah
to talk to you you give him seven
minutes screw the panel have him talk to
you for the whole show like let's dig
into this
and i realized that like oh wait a
minute like
people who just want to have their
opinions reinforced they don't care
about
long-form dialogue you know
that's why people don't see it they want
sound bites that they can go to their
family and then when their
cousin comes in and goes you know we
really need nationalized healthcare they
can go
oh yeah here's the sound bite i heard on
this
dan bongino show that makes you sound
dumb
that's all they want they don't want
dialogue they don't want to get anywhere
it's tiresome so i just don't do that on
my show i'm like no
we're gonna have a long format
discussion i'm gonna push back where
pushing is needed to open something up
more
but i'm not gonna push back just to be
like see audience i disagree with this
guy
virtue signal virtue signal virtue
signal i disagree
a lot of what you do so effectively is
research before the the show
and you know i wanted well first of all
i was curious because it took you know
took a while for me to do it
did did kobe have to go through the same
you know like weeks and weeks of back
and forth with the producer like on his
question and answer his five topics his
take away his giveaway
did kobe bryant fill out my show prep
form that i made you fill out is that
what you're trying to ask
me absolutely not he did not okay fine
i would be mad if he did because that's
special yeah he's finished
okay yeah okay but only only people like
kobe are in that exalted hierarchy
correct yeah no i you know in the thing
is i
also i didn't mind it actually helped a
lot because i didn't know you i didn't
know what you would ask me and i didn't
know
you know i mean i have followed you for
literally the better part of a decade
but i didn't know like what is my
episode going to be like so at least it
gave me some structure is what to expect
so i i do think
even for kobe it probably would have
been good but but anyway go ahead yeah
so so i'm able to do i do
10 to 20 hours of prep for every guest
as you know but uh for kobe
it was easy enough for me to
to prep on my own because there's so
much information there i didn't really
but his publicist gave me a lot of stuff
to work with as well which is helpful
but you know i don't have to worry about
that stuff with kobe because there
is such an obvious angle to take with
somebody like that
um with you or with us an author
that i'm exploring i want to know what i
want to know what they're trying to
bring across because the last thing you
want to do
the last thing you want to do is go and
interview somebody
well i wouldn't say the last thing one
of the last things you want to do
is go in and and try to
interview somebody about something they
don't want to talk about and then
they're trying to skillfully or not drag
the conversation
in another direction yeah like
with kobe i knew that there was a lot of
low-hanging fruit with basketball
yeah but i didn't want to talk about
basketball so what i told his publicist
was
i really want to focus on creativity
parenting running a business i don't
really care about basketball so you can
be relieved and know that and they were
like and we want to focus on
and there was like other things that
obviously had hit the news in recent
years that they didn't want me to
really dive into for obvious reasons
and and i was like don't worry and a lot
of people are like that like a lot of
a lot of personalities are going
you got to sort of think for them like
is general petraeus going to come into
this conversation
thinking i'm going to attack him for
this affair that he had
super sick of talking about right right
because
that is something that is a nightmare
for a publicist is tiring for him
and he doesn't have to subject himself
to this crap anymore it's going to start
you off in an adversarial relation you
know almost almost
especially when they know that it could
be out there it's almost worse than if
you just get out of the way and say
either we're going to talk about it or
not
give them the option and i guess you
know one thing i wonder about you know
because you do so much research and i
think it was you who told me this or
except i'd say told me i
i feel like the ear is so deep that
you're literally in my earbuds you know
like hours and hours a week and with a
lot of other pot james is like that
tim ferriss is like that you're
listening and these people are like
literally embedded in your head and as
carl sagan said about books
he said you know you have an author who
wrote something little scribbles on dead
paper undead trees
and then their voice is in your head and
it's no wonder that books
and audio format like podcasts are so
are so influential visceral
and influential of the human mind and i
just wonder
you know one thing you said a long time
ago as i said was
and i can can't remember exactly but it
was like you don't ask
you you get all the low-hanging fruit
out of the way like you're not going to
talk about that you're just
you just blow past that because you want
to get beyond the talking points
and i'm wondering like with books it's
hard for me i have a lot of authors on
and they want to talk about their book
but there's a balance between like like
a lot of people want the audiobook
in the podcast in other words they don't
even want to buy the audiobook they
don't want to buy the written
you know who has time to read a book so
it's like tell me your whole book and on
the podcast and then the host doesn't
have to do research
you know because they're the author is
going to tell about it i mean how do you
balance that how do you how do you get
it so that you get to the really
interesting stuff um the stuff the
exclusive stuff because i think that's
what as a podcaster
is so interesting stories that people
have no like i asked noam chomsky about
alien intelligent like no i thought he
was going to say you know
idiot you're a professor chancellor's
professor physics [ __ ] like like
and we talked for 30 minutes about it it
was fascinating and he had never talked
about it
wait sorry that last part was a little
confusing he'd never talked about what
alien linguistics like how do you
communicate with an ant because he's
known as the father of linguist modern
linguistics
right and i said but a lot of his thesis
is that link
language is learned as you're knowing
from jaden it's almost all nonverbal
like he's learning grammar
like he might say something like amino
or something but he'll put it subject
and the verb will agree you know he
won't say like uh daddy and mommy is
going you know whatever maybe he will i
don't know how much he's talking to be
honest but you'll see as he gets older
um and kids learn that but they don't
learn it from the you know they don't
sit down at a language course so they're
learning non
non-verbally and i said how could you
communicate to an alien civilization
that you can't see
you can't do the nonverbal
communications cues with an alien you're
just communicating with morse code
is it possible even in principle
linguistically to teach an
alien civilization uh language and that
was something he had never
thought about and i was kind of scared
to ask him that question and you know
james alter she says whenever you're
scared to ask
you know that's the question you have to
ask you know it's like james campbell
the
the treasurer you seek is in the cave
you fear to enter
um so i wonder about getting back to
like you specifically and the advice
that you gave me and millions of others
who listen to you like
how do you get to the you know someone
who's introverted someone who's not
really used to these for the format that
you're involved in
not to divulge the secret of his or her
book but to get at the exclusive like
how do you get to that point is it the
research beforehand
is it just your own inherent curiosity
and passion
yeah you know that's a really good
question
i i do read the book i do take a lot of
notes i do go over the book a lot
depending on the author
like if if there's more to the author
than the book
for kobe i didn't read the children's
book and go like let's talk about
the magic tennis player or whatever the
book was you know
i wanted to talk about him um and with
you i wanted to talk about you
and and we there was plenty in the book
that we probably touched on but i didn't
need to go
and get like the book outline on the
other hand
if i'm talking to an undercover uh
former undercover fbi agent who does
art crime i'm basically going through a
lot of the stories in the book with
fewer details harp honing in on a couple
that were like really incredible having
him tell them
like he was there similar to how they
were written but in or
oral format you know like there's
there's more
to there's more to it um
i don't really this is an interesting
question because i didn't really have to
think about how do i get them to tell
some of the time i will literally say
hey can you tell the story about
that time you were being chased by the
french art thieves and you were running
with this like
rembrandt that turned out and it got
destroyed and it turned out to be a copy
and you almost got fired and
felt really bad but then it was just
junk anyway like and then i'll cut that
out of the show
yeah and then he'll go yeah i mean that
was the
that was the time i was in geneva and
i'm like okay start like
one time i was in geneva then we just
cut that out and he tells the story
you know it's all prompted really
directly which is kind of like
that's really there's no genius to that
you know
um other times i'll say something along
the lines of
now what's this i hear about you running
away in geneva with a rembrandt
well okay it wasn't a rembrandt it
turned out well let me tell you let me
start
from the beginning then i'll leave it in
and then they just tell a story i'm
prompting it i already know the story
it's not like i just heard someone says
it's not like i make it sound like
someone said ask him about the time he
was running around in geneva with a
rembrandt
you know and then i make it sound like i
was just at a bar with one of his
buddies and he
told me to do that but i've read the
whole story right i've read the whole
thing
right um so it's kind of like
cross-examination when you're a lawyer
where
you don't ask there's this old sort of
youtube with this great
cross-examiner who since i think passed
and he taught at yale in like the 70s
and 60s
and he goes never ask a question if you
don't know the answer that you're going
to get
that's what that brother always says
that's it's true for cross-examination
it's not
true for podcasts i don't want people to
like you
you should be asking questions you don't
know the answer to in podcasts but if
you're trying to elicit a story and
you're pretty sure it's good
then then you ask the question knowing
you're going to get the answer what you
don't want to do is go
tell me about the time and then they go
oh uh yeah that was nothing yeah like if
that happens cut it out you know you
have the luxury of doing that you don't
you can't do that on cross-examination
but with with other things i will simply
generate enough rapport
with the guest where i go so do you
think
that if you hadn't been convicted of
this crime
you would have been doing abcd and
they'll go
i don't know maybe not you know i don't
know what they're going to say they
might be like oh yeah i wanted to do
that since i was a kid
me going to prison that was just a
roadblock on the way to my true calling
as a painter
speaker right yeah yeah or they go you
know i don't know and you say well
because it seems like this
got thrown are you a type of person that
believes everything happens for a reason
and they'll go
uh not really you know i think the the
reason that this happened was because i
was like
yeah i was an [ __ ] when i was 20 so i
went to jail you know or my parents left
me on a doorstep when i was a kid so i
joined a gang like if that's the reason
then yeah
yeah right you know so you try to get
there but that's because any answer is
fine
yeah but the beauty of podcasting is you
can cut out answers that are really lame
and and people go oh you edit it's not
fair
well you if you listen to podcasts that
are like two hours long
and they're not edited and you listen to
enough of them you start to go
why didn't you edit that yeah i'm doing
a video so it's it's hard for me to edit
like the segway and actually that brings
up something that i want to
ask you about for a while sure in real
time do you have metrics in your head
like you actually gave me one of mine
a few minutes ago so i'm patting myself
on the back but like when a guest says
to me
that's an interesting question or i've
never been asked that before or
wow or just sits there like you know i
let the silence do the work
and i'm just an amateur compared to i'm
being serious jordan but but like you
use
do you have any real-time metrics that
like i'm having a good time especially
in covid where
we're not face-to-face like we were
together we could hang out beforehand
slap the backs whatever
and uh but in over over you know the
airwaves so to speak
how do you know in real time you're
doing a good job as an interviewer
that's a that's also a pretty good
question because you know
a lot of times you don't know in real
time if you're doing a good job
i think for me
how do i know if i'm doing a good job as
an interviewer
in the moment probably because
the other person seems
engaged in the conversation um they seem
excited to be talking about
like i don't right now because i'm
thinking but they seem excited to be
talking about put their phone down stop
checking
instagram yeah there's some of that
there's some of that
um yeah they're engaged with what it is
that they are
talking about but also there's a
friendliness and rapport and ease that
goes into the conversation
where they're not thinking
seemingly about
getting their agenda across you know
they're not going
that's nice brian but in my book how to
get paid to speak on stage
i just you know you've broken them of
their autopilot response
that's part of it but you've broken them
of that
not because you're like shut up about
your book but because
they're they're just going this guy
they're like lost in the conversation
you know which is what you want they're
engrossed in the conversation is
probably better
and the listener is also engrossed
theoretically in the conversation at
that point as well
if you're wrestling with the guest like
you know if you're going
how do you get well in my book how to
speak from the stage brian thanks for
asking
i discussed the three crucial points
about this and you're like yeah
that's great tell me about when your
travels to north korea well when i was
in north korea
before i'd written the three magical
points of speaking from stage
yeah you know if you're wrestling with
them then the listeners like
oh this guy sucks and they're not going
to probably blame the host if you have
rapport with your
your audience um but you want the guest
to just be kind of like
screw it this is a fun conversation yeah
let's talk about psychedelics you know
what or whatever you're talking about um
i don't tend to go that route but
like you want somebody to come on
in theory to talk about their their
children's book and then you just go
so this is kind of a dark topic but when
i had kobe bryant on and
he's fresh in my mind recently because
somebody just asked me about him before
the show
so i don't mean to keep sort of
name-dropping
but it is a good it is a good
opportunity to showcase this as an
example
uh he was talking you know he wanted to
talk about his children's book
but he didn't really want to talk about
basketball which is great because i
didn't either and he didn't want to talk
about certain other things and i said
you know do you ever think about now
that you're writing children's books
it's clear that you're thinking about
parenting
i don't know about you but for me you
know i had my child uh
just a few months ago this is in
september my kid was born in july so i
just had a kid and and that's we focused
a lot on that and i said do you ever
think about
what happens when you're gone and he
said yeah you know
that i do think about what happens when
i'm gone and i think some of this
hit the cutting room floor because we
weren't thinking how relevant it would
be
and he said yeah you know and after the
show we were talking he goes
yeah man so i you know i got to tell you
that mortality thing is something that i
really do think about and it's easy to
think you're never going to die when
you're on the basketball court and
you know millions of people are looking
at you but when you have kids you just
realize how fragile your life is and how
fragile their life is and
how fragile your time together is and i
thought and i remember being like
yeah that's so true can you sign this
book thanks it was really like that but
2020 hindsight i'm like man that would
have been good tape
you know because it was so truthful and
it was such an
interesting thread and it was such a
real part of the conversation
that if you're really attached to your
agenda you miss that and you're doing a
good job as an interviewer if you
realize that your agenda is to provide
value for the audience not to like
get answers about what's going on i'm
not a journalist
i'm not sitting there on 60 minutes
going
yeah did you kill her did you kill her
roger did you
believe it or not and in physics they're
controversial figures that are
accused of self-promotion i mean you
know it could probably be like they
write books about it right
books about awards they didn't even win
those guys
and then and they have an agenda so
people will write like how come you
didn't ask him about the time his
employees quit
in 1997 i'm like i'm not like leslie
stahl you know like i'll give you your
money back how about this you know
but you know in science i think there's
a credibility i want to ask you a
corollary to what you just said because
you talk about these things and actually
i've started to do just as you're saying
maybe in part inspired by similar ideas
but like i asked my guests as i will
with you uh in about 90 minutes from now
in in a few minutes i'll ask you these
three
questions that are really kind of these
deep questions thinking about the deep
future of yourself personally it's
humanity as a whole
and then advice to your former self and
i do it in a hopefully
interesting way related to sir arthur c
clarke but before we do that i wanted to
just turn to
um you know your life has been
documented in
podcast form since you were what 26
years old and
all all the different changes that
you've undergone it's kind of the
corollary to kobe kobe had this one
opportunity is on your show basically
the only podcast that of of
real value and interest that i i i'm
aware of that personally
i mean maybe he went on other shows but
uh but the point is you got to ask him
certain questions you got to interact
with him
uh and that was this brief snapshot of
him with you we've seen you evolve since
26 year olds starting a huge podcast
breaking up with that i don't want to
get into the breakup with the uh i'll
just call them aoc
folks uh the the uh that it's been well
documented in your podcast and elsewhere
we don't have to talk about it
but then um but then evolving to now
being
married being a father moving from l.a
moving to the now building your house
this evolution we get to see you and i
wonder like
are there things sometimes i get a kid
like why did you have this person on
like three years ago or like
why'd you go on this person's show like
it's very harmful like how do you deal
with
the fact that you've evolved you we all
make mistakes um are there things that
you regret
are there things that you can do
differently and learn from these
mistakes because
i i feel like a lot of podcasting is
kind of like failure porn it's like oh
well
it is yeah what do you make of stuff
yeah so what do you make of that is that
is that a problem
are we reaching peak podcast or at least
that that branch of it
um no i don't think we're reaching peak
podcast i just think there's a lot of
people that have really
kind of like mediocre at best unoriginal
ideas maybe
um i
i'm trying not to be like an a-hole
about this like oh my show's good and
everyone else
sucks like that's not really what i
think at all i i think
there's just a lot of people that go oh
i don't have an idea for a show but i
want to be an influencer so i'm gonna
i'm gonna do shows uh with entrepreneurs
let's see if those are taken oh crap
there's 8
000 of these literally uh oh i'm gonna
do
unsuccessful entrepreneurs because those
people are easy to get
versus like super successful people or
i'll like only talk about failures not
not talk about like
how tom's shoes was built i'll talk
about like how tom's shoes almost failed
and like all the bad ideas that guy had
before that
and there's some value there like to not
look at all entrepreneurs as like
immediate lottery winners
even though many of them are awesome um
yeah i think a lot of them are
the successful ones that we see you know
they've won the business lottery in some
way
but like you know
there's nothing that interesting about
it in my perspective i
i got lucky because when i started
podcasting in 2006
there were not that many
shows so me being like i'm going to do a
show about
dating in relationships that focuses on
like nonverbal communication and
influence you know and then like turn it
into like dating and pick up e type
stuff because i'm in my 20s
it was fine and no one was like this is
misogynist because it wasn't
right and also we didn't have cancel
culture right so nobody was looking for
problems with it like there were a few
people that wrote in that were like
i don't like this because it has to do
with dating and that's wrong because
you should just be yourself i'm like
okay this is just some crazy low
self-esteem person
the other x thousand people listening
think it's great so i don't care
those people didn't bother me we like i
said we didn't have cancel culture so it
didn't really make a difference
and then it evolved into i'm just going
to talk about what i'm interested in
and oh i seem to have a skill for
conversation that i've developed over
literally 14 years almost of doing this
right so that got really easy for me and
now i can
be arrogant enough to name my show the
jordan harbinger show and it's not like
this ridiculous
like oh you wish people record like no
there's a lot of search queries from my
name especially in podcast directories
so it works great
right um but for a lot of folks there
are there are issues i think you have to
examine your motivations when you start
a show are you just trying to be an
influencer if so just like
i get it but you need to find something
that is a value
you have to be an advocate for your
audience you know i again going back to
the law thing
as a lawyer i have a i have a fiduciary
duty to the client i have an ethical
duty to the client i look at my
listeners of the jordan harbinger show
as clients in that i have an ethical i
have an ethical duty to them
they have to there's nothing for sale
for the jordan harbinger show but i
you are paying with your attention so if
i want to retain your attention
and you want to retain me as the
quote-unquote as the host of a show that
you listen to
i can't be like here's this self-serving
thing where i benefit
i have to be like the deal is you listen
to the show
you occasionally support the sponsors of
the jordan harbinger show which allows
me to do this show and give you the
services for free
and people are like cool and in return
i'm not going to lie to you i'm not
going to tell you this mattress is great
if it sucks
i'm only going to recommend things that
i really like i'm not going to hammer
you with ads i'm not going to be extra
salesy i'm not going to hide the ball
i'm also not going to present people to
you uh under cover of oh this person's
great because they gave me 25 grand i'm
not going to do that
i'm not going to bring in perspectives
that i think are harmful
not because i'm your parent but because
i have your best interest in mind as
not your lawyer but as somebody who is
going to act as an advocate for you
so i'm not i might bring in a guy like
roger stone and say make a decision for
yourself
but look at what he said and it's it's
not pretty but i wanted you to get an
unvarnished look at this guy
you know or i'll having a scientist or
somebody like you who's like here's this
thing that i learned
and i'm not like tell them the thing
they can buy where i get a kickback we
don't do that we don't do any of that on
the show
and so people who are coming up with new
show ideas or running a podcast
i find that they often have their ethics
muddled and
and i mean muddled if as if they were an
attorney
not like they're personally unethical
but i think there's a lot of shows that
they're like
yeah i just wanted to bring the best
stories of
entrepreneurs to my audience something
something something that's
like there's like 9 000 shows like that
but if you
really dig it's like no they're trying
to sell their book
because they have an online course and
it's part of the funnel and then they're
like
they're like an entrepreneur yeah
they're an entrepreneur coach where
they're gonna teach you how to do this
this and this and it's like
so this is lead gen for you you're not
trying to find
you're not trying to get people to learn
from these
oh you're not trying to only get people
to learn from these entrepreneurs that
have failed
you're trying to get people who are
struggling in entrepreneurship so that
they will pay you their money to
fill their right to fill their need and
and that's fine
but you better put that crap out on the
table and not be like i'm just a casual
podcast host
hanging out delivering knowledge no
you're trying to get people in a sales
funnel
and you're filtering them in because
they're struggling and that's not
deceptive or despicable
unless it's deceptive or despicable and
then you should stop
is there a danger you know before i want
to make sure we have time to talk about
networking and academia and elsewhere
but before we get there um you know is
there like i kind of see you
and i see other people james or tim fer
like and there's this there's this
growth phenomena and
there's some name for it in silicon
valley you probably know what it is but
like
you get so big it becomes really hard to
deliver extra value or to benefit more
without spending a lot more money to
move the needle to get more
listeners as is the really most
important metric
um you know like is did you get to a
point where you're like a victim of your
own success like
i i figured my kids yesterday were
saying like oh daddy you've got you know
so many subscribers because they see my
you know things and i go do ads
sometimes they come up on there i don't
get ads bad money but
they'll see an ad or something they'll
say like oh well joe biden was on your
podcast i'm like nah not exactly
uh but but the point you know because
some ad roles before an interview that i
do
but um but i was they're like oh well
you should get more more
people i'm like you know there's a story
in 1984 george orwell's story where the
donkey
um i forget his name benjamin benjamin's
his name and uh
the pig comes up to him and says oh
you've got this resplendent tail you
know it's so beautiful
and the donkey says yeah the tail keeps
away the flies
and the pig says oh that's great and the
dog says no i'd rather not
have the flies and not need the tail
it's like how big do you want to get
like what's your ultimate mission with
jhs
as we call it uh you know like do you
ever find it like worrisome like you
just like i gotta be on somebody else's
show to get more listeners to my like
eventually it saturates right so what is
the ultimate goal and like can you
become a victim of your own success like
the end game
if it's not the funnel if it's not you
know legion for your network
and you give away your networking course
so uh you know so like
you're like what is what is the ultimate
what is your ultimate goal i guess is
interesting to me is her book
what are you gonna do
for me i'm not even necessarily
sure like it's like i said it's
something i'm dealing with right now
where there's a lot of people that are
like write a book but
that's not really my core competency
also i think it might be a good thing to
do in a game changer but it's like
where do i put my time what i'm looking
at right now
is build a larger audience with which i
can
generate more advertising revenue from
sponsors because i i realize what i
truly love
is having the conversations you know
like
is it a jewel thief that i'm talking to
a famous jewel thief
who's now telling people like hey kids
stay in school basically is
like his motto um or am i talking with
somebody who is uh a nobel prize losing
scientist
am i talking with somebody who's written
a book on poker but
is really you know maria konicova like
the human element of that am i talking
to a professional athlete
i just love the conversations i mean
there's a lot there's a
it's a hell of a lot of fun to read a
book and go man i wonder about that
oh i guess i'll write that down and ask
the author when i talk to them in a week
and you know have a personal
conversation with them and sit down with
them that's a really cool privilege it's
really fun to create and i want to
create more of that
and right now i make a healthy living
doing it but i'd be a fool to believe
that
the cost of advertising or the the money
that advertising generates is gonna stay
the same forever
like that could easily go down the
economy could hit a dip
uh i i don't wanna have to be in a
position where i go oh shoot i can't
make ends meet
introducing the jordan harbinger be a
famous podcaster
you know i don't want to have to do that
crap so the best thing i can do right
now is scale
the show and also scaling the show gives
you some really cool opportunities
because then you get to talk to even
more
hard to reach guests you know i'd rate
dalio on the other day and i'm like oh i
could do with more guys like this like
he's really really interesting guy
so i want to do that and i want to be
the
scaling up gives me the luxury of not
having to do things that other people
say i should do as i scale up like have
courses
do live events i don't want to do any of
that stuff yeah i i've done coaching
before i've done training before it
doesn't mean it's a scam not all of it's
a scam not all of it
is unethical of course but i don't like
doing it
i don't like doing it but i also
understand why people have to do it
because they're like oh
i can't make ad money so i do need a
product that's like
duck tales you know if it's like you
know take what we're doing now
and then you know convert it to some
course just about how to be a good
podcaster or whatever
you know i i'm doing that but it's gonna
be like it's gonna be like
30 bucks yeah it's not gonna be like
three thousand bucks no that's right
right
tony robbins and uh plunge pools and
everything else yeah exactly no i'm
doing a podcasting class and it's going
to be it focused on interviews not on
what microphone to buy and stuff and
it's going to be
it conducting a good interview and it's
going to be so cheap
and affordable that's how you're
supposed to frame it it's going to be so
affordable
that even if you're in college and
you're like i just kind of like
podcasting and i want to get better at
it you can you can buy this
and it's not like you don't have to take
out more federal loans to get it
no i will be there and i will be grade
grubbing as i always have been
throughout my academic career there you
go
and actually that segues nicely to uh
some topics about about academia and
science in particular
uh so you know i think of you as kind of
mr network and your catchphrase you know
dig the well before you're thirsty
yes and i want to be a little uh a
little bit of the 60 minutes type with
you
so when i hear that um i understand what
you mean but if i tell my
scientist colleagues that you know like
well we need to network or you need to
get to know this person because this
person could be
useful to us someday you know when
you're when you're in a bind or you need
something and and that your network is
your net worth and the other cliches
but but certainly uh it comes across to
some people
especially those in academia um as
transactional
it's like oh you're you're networking
and you're reaching out to
you know kobe bryant's realtor because
you eventually want to get kobe on your
show because you know that'll get a lot
of
and then you'll get ad revenue and so we
don't listen to einstein because he had
a great
speaking voice or what you know in fact
yeah it's awful barely yeah it's funny i
i don't think i've ever heard him
in a recording it's very very few
recordings of him but again when
nam chomsky i could barely hear what he
was saying uh but what he's saying is so
much more important he doesn't have a
course or some
you know some multi-level marketing
scheme the pyramids you know guys 92
years old but but the question i have
for you is like how do you
um walk that line between not wanting to
be this
greasy-haired uh transactional guy like
i am you know but
how do you uh is it is it truly
authentic or you know you have this
networking course and so forth which i
find very beneficial even as a scientist
and and these soft skills do
distinguish some of the things that i do
and i resonate very strongly with it
what do you say to people like
colleagues of mine like it's it's kind
of slimy like why are you doing this you
know you should just
let your merit your meritocracy it's
that's the way science should be you
should just be technically brilliant
yeah i i mean look um
is that real is that is that real like
is there a such thing as i guess there
are probably plenty of people where it's
like
they got here solely based on the value
of their work and they never
self-promoted but
i don't really know how true that is
i think it's meant to look that way and
i think it does look that way for a lot
of folks but
that's kind of like saying i i mean give
me an example of somebody who supposedly
has done something
and has never been people that are
horrible horrible i mean like they used
to say paul dirac who won the nobel
prize
you know discovered anti-matter
essentially and they used to say
dirac never uses two words when none
will do you know he was like so task
attorney like they're basically
scientists
the most you know the the kind of um you
know cliche is that we're
you know we're extremely introverted i
think i use the joke and you're you know
they're they're extroverted if they look
at your shoes when they talk to their
own
yeah and so like um so it's seen as a
sign of inauthenticity
even though some of the most you know
important best scientists and
you know folks like jim simons who i did
have on my show he's called the world's
smartest billionaire
he said one of the most important skills
of a scientist is to be a good salesman
it doesn't mean you're i'm not selling
it i lose all the money that i
you know that i get like it all goes out
the payroll i don't make a single profit
i get papers i get citations from you
know me and my students get phds
we we're i'm in a money losing business
but the the point is like you're
perceived negatively like carl sagan
never was in the uh national academy of
sciences and they said because
you know he was such a great community
that's a little doll you know
of him uh finger puppet but they said
you know he was really
penalized almost and like i was talking
to janet levin who you'd like you'd love
to talk to her she was just on tim
ferriss's show
and she was saying like when she was on
my show she was like we won't penalize
you if you write a book
but we're not going to give you any
credit for doing like it's seen as like
almost outreach and the soft skills of a
scientist
are if they're not penalized they're
certainly not celebrated
and so in this kind of you know whereas
a lawyer
you know you have to be a good
communicator i mean it's most of what
you do
and i actually agree that it is a huge
thing to have a network
yeah i mean you gave an example actually
on your show a few months back with a
student who reached
out to you know one of her professors
who did win a nobel prize or something
like that and
they developed this thing and she
eventually became an intern in his lab
and so far i think it was at stanford
um so i do think it's important but uh i
guess the question is
how do you avoid it because i if it's
genuine i think it's it's fine to do it
but how do you avoid that kind of
um patina that's perceived as
inauthentic
well digging the well for a purpose like
for you to drink so like you're gonna
dig
you know so that uh dalio comes on the
show and whatever
yeah i'm accusing you i'm just speaking
you definitely need to dig the well
before you get thirsty so build
relationships before you need them
i think the key is you really do need to
help other people without the
expectation of getting something in
return so
if i'm only helping you to get something
for me yeah of course you're gonna have
a slimy
and well-deserved slimy reputation but
if i'm helping people because i want to
see them succeed because the more
successful people that i'm around the
higher the chance of me succeeding
there's nothing selfish really in that
like
it's not completely altruistic because
i'm hoping that if you're successful and
she's successful and she's successful
and he's successful that i'm
then going to have some of that rub off
on me or they're going to pull me up
but that's good for everyone so i don't
see a problem with that
the problem is that a lot of sci and
i've noticed this with scientists i
actually have trained scientists with
networking
and skills like that before and what's
funny is a lot of these
big phd professors who are like famous
scientists
they're like man it's so hard to find
qualified amazing people to come into my
lab and blah blah blah and i'm like well
why
well it's just looking for a needle in a
haystack and you know it's hard to find
people that are going to get along
and then meanwhile these scientists are
like i don't want to come across as a
self-promoting
promotional person i'm like this guy's
running a lab and he wants to meet the
most qualified people and you're over
here being like a better hide
right yeah what is that doing for you
and what good is that doing for the
person who wants to find somebody to
work with
you're not helping anyone it's like this
this false or real modesty that
represents or manifests itself as like
i want to actually harm my career
because if i look like i'm trying to
further my career
other people might not like me and it's
like other people that don't have
enough self-esteem or self-confidence to
help their own career might not like you
now you're just crabs in a bucket right
have you heard that where like the crabs
trying to crawl and the other the last
grab
yeah so so that's what is going on in
science
from what i understand and from what
i've seen and i'm thinking oh my gosh i
get it because you don't want to come
across like you're the important product
and not the science
there's obviously a balance in which you
do that where you go look
i've got some decent research i would
love to contribute to your research
because you're amazing and this research
is amazing and we're going to
do something that changes the field
together make it about the field make it
about the person you're trying to
to get and work under because you
realize you have a long career ahead of
yourself
there's nothing wrong in recognizing the
work you've put in or that you're an
upstart that could actually have some
potential
there's nothing wrong with this you have
to get over the idea
that you speaking for your ideas
is somehow completely selfish because
imagine if doctors thought that way you
know i think i figured out that you can
put mold on infections but uh
who wants to hear from little old me
come on
right yeah so right so there's this
actual
complete inversion of reality that takes
place so a friend of mine darren lapommy
is a professor here at ucsd
he runs a very popular channel of
youtube as well and he has uh he has a
you know it's basically called how to
how to uh win friends and influence
people after dale carnegie's but it's
first
it's from um nano engineers so these
aren't the most you know
gregarious effervescent personalities
and yet he's teaching them like what do
you think is and he does a poll like
what do you think
is the breakdown of importance in your
career the so-called you know technical
ability raw intellectual horsepower
time in the lab time in front of the
textbook and the computer programming
coding whatever
versus you know learning how to speak
getting a speaking coach
uh doing uh presentations going to
toastmasters
uh versus and it's like 80 20. is
basically what they think it is and in
reality and then he shows
it's a compliment it's 20 80. it's
basically exactly the opposite
you look at all the soft skills it takes
to be a professor i mean there's a joke
that you know
isadore rabbi used to say you know like
professors are paid to do research
to find new sources of money and if
you're a gentleman or a gentle lady you
put some energy into teaching it's like
the thing that we're at least trained
for where you never get a course and
here's how you teach
but we also never get a course and
here's how you speak and and these are
the things that we do most often and i
feel like
it'd be great to have a version of the
networking you know six minute
networking
but for uh for scientists for engineers
and
you know i think i think it would be
very valuable because there's a lot of
us and and it's it's perceived to be one
of the more important careers that there
is the stem fields
um so i want to uh say because i know
you're gonna run out of time soon
so i don't wanna i don't wanna miss out
on the questions that i wanted to ask
couple just like rapid fire questions
when should a podcaster decide when to
monetize like i i'll be quite frank
you know i bought the manscaping i
bought the i bought the
the bio optimizers for the other side of
the of the of the body
like how do you uh when is it too soon
to like go after
pod i'm not planning to go after it but
for those of my audience who might be
interested in podcasting
when it you know is it a mistake to try
to get advertisers too soon
yeah um it it doesn't really matter it's
just you do have to trade
there is a trade-off like if if you've
got 5 000 downloads per episode and
you're going to end up getting
you know 100 bucks an episode if you can
do your advertising
in a way that's not that annoying you go
ahead do it you know like
why not or 500 bucks an episode if this
pays for the production it makes it
worth your time do it why not
just be conscious of the fact that your
audience
might be a little resistant to
commercialism i wouldn't go from having
zero ads to having four in every show
like i would work my way up as the show
length
increases the value increases uh there's
nothing wrong with that
on the other hand if you are selling a
course
and you have ads and you know you're
stuffing it in there and you're taking
paid guests like i would be wary of that
because
again you have to be an advocate for
your audience like what's good for them
what is
what is good for the person listening
if you can only have sponsors that you
really like and care about that's even
better
right so it's never it no
there is a time that it's too early i
won't say it's never too early um
if you have a enough of an audience to
make your ads
meaningful in terms of revenue you can
do that you just have to be very careful
of how you commercialize like
i am also very careful with sponsors you
know the people that offer me the most
money
are those people that are like yeah we
have these hair growth pills or
something right
child dysfunction and they're like we'll
give you a hundred dollars cpm
four times what you get paid everywhere
else you're gonna make 10 grand from
these ad spots and i'm like
i can't sit here and tell my audience
about penis pills like it's not gonna
happen
so you have to be very careful because
you have to play the long game
yeah um and it's easy to get sucked into
taking ad money and treating it like the
short game
but you just you want to be as careful
as humanly possible with your
sponsorship
with your audience yeah and our friend
you know james altitude you know he got
a lot of flack for like being a bitcoin
promoter
in the 2017 time frame and he says he
regrets it but not really because
there were so many kind of negative uh
bitcoin
outfits out there that newsletters and
just scams and he thought they were all
going out
going out i don't know can you go out of
business with the bitcoin i forget how
it works i actually don't deal in it
but he you know he said it was actually
a good thing that he did it because he
was only really suggesting that they
back legitimate products or whatever
and so he's not he regrets it but not
fully uh oh is the same thing true of
advertise like
look if you don't advertise they're
gonna go somewhere else they're gonna go
on uh i don't know joe rogan or you know
whoever your competition is
and uh and i don't know if joe even does
that but but the point is
um you know someone's gonna do it why
not be you so to speak
uh i guess the counter argument is you
don't want to lose your credibility
with your audience and they are your
customers uh uh
you know i guess exactly yeah i guess
because i'm not you know directly but
yes right
i mean the thing is it's like i'm not
thinking of
oh well if i don't take the money
someone else is gonna take good
let them take it let them abuse their
audience i'm not going to do it it's
kind of like saying
well you know some people beat up their
kids i might as well do it
what are you gonna do that like you're
abusing your audience like i'm not even
trying to make light of that like
it's it's like not even a joke it's like
you're mistreating someone why would you
do that just because some other people
do it's like
is that a good reason to do something
because somebody else does it
if your friends were all jumping off a
bridge would you do it i mean it's the
same thing
your grandma always said there's no
reason to do that um
you see people mistreat others around
them all the time it's just just because
we can't see them and they're listening
to a product that we record
and we're abusing their trust does that
mean we should do it just because the
consequences are further removed
no like you wouldn't mistreat going back
to my bad example earlier you wouldn't
mistreat your own family why are you
going to mistreat people
go back to to what i said with you have
to be an advocate for the audience
would you mistreat your own clients if
you're an advocate for them you can't
you're ethically bound to not do so so
don't accept money
for something that you think is crap
because you want the money
like that's why i do encourage people to
monetize what they create so that they
can keep doing it but i also encourage
them not to become dependent upon that
monetization
so that they then have to do things that
are not quite
yeah you don't want to have to optimize
the ads that go into the show at the
expense of it
i've got ads in my show but i could make
a whole lot more if i had more ads yeah
i could do more shows with crappier
guests
you know and i see i see certain hosts
do this there are hosts that have like
any youtuber on that will also share the
episode and i'm like your show sucks
you know you still suck so you'll have
anyone on there mental no don't ask
jordan to share those twos
but but like it there are people that
are like oh i had this guy who owns a
clothing brand and all i say after
everything he says
whoa it's so inspiring man cool great uh
you know that guy
yeah yeah we know exactly everyone knows
who i'm talking about because that's the
whole show
and it's like oh well i'm making all
this money from ads cool but everyone
thinks you're a clown and your churn is
like crazy because the more people that
find you
they listen to you for a week and
they're like okay
all right one more uh quick uh rapid
fire question
um you do a lot on social media
instagram twitter
less a little less on twitter instagram
you have a huge following linkedin
uh what appeals to you about those three
different platforms are there others uh
and which which of them has the least
amount of trolls in your experience
which which what has the least amount
which of the social media platforms
facebook
instagram linkedin twitter has the least
amount of trolls
linkedin yeah linkedin that's what i say
yeah for sure right
it's like they're they're they combine
you know the the you know kind of
fun of of connecting with friends but a
little bit of desperation if they want
to get a job
yeah so they're not going to blow yeah
exactly great that uh you're there's a
little bit of like hey are you hiring
i'm really good at you know
that video fine but there's not like
i don't get like hi babe how are you
reply here to talk to like my filipino
scantily clad like that you you report
that
in a second i get is it me or do a lot
of people get like
random women from southeast asia that
are scantily clad in their inbox and
everything i don't i don't know
i would never admit to that if i did i
get that all the time in my inbox and
maybe that's just my platform yeah i get
like i have an alternative uh a solution
for the uh
origin of the universe and if you help
me publish it you'll share the nobel
prize that you lost yeah
uh i don't i guess you don't get those
but i get different crazies
yeah we all have yeah it's we have our
own niche craziness okay
last questions that i ask all of my
guests come on the into the impossible
podcast speaking of jordan harbinger
the effervescent the brilliant the
incomparable jordan harbinger
um first question i ask and and they all
answer it is
what is your solution to quantizing
gravity in a four-dimensional space-time
framework
uh 42. okay good good okay check
uh seriously so i'm gonna ask questions
that some of them are related to
uh to sir arthur c clarke the namesake
of this podcast in the center that i
co-direct
here in san diego but the first one
actually has to do with
a piece of not immaterial wisdom you
remember from my book because i know you
read it cover to cover twice in an audio
form
that alfred nobel has the most famous
will in history he has a will that says
you know where his money would go he had
no wife no children so he left all of
his money pretty much to go to the nobel
prize
but in the nobel prize it was monetary
will like normal wills that you learned
about in estates and trust in law school
but it also had an ethical component in
that the prizes were to go to somebody
who who created the best invention that
had the greatest benefit to mankind
and so in doing so it was an ethical
will it wasn't just a material will
and i want to ask you in terms of your
ethical will when you reach
the biblical age of 120 and you pass on
what sorts of wisdom or values would you
like to articulate
uh in in words or in written form uh for
not only your your child your children
hopefully uh your wife etc
but for humanity what piece of wisdom or
or knowledge do you find is sort of uh
most pertinent
for people in the future i really think
that the
networking relationship advice that i
teach is probably
as of right now the best takeaway
because it works for everyone
it helps everyone the more people do it
the better off we all are
dale carnegie started that trend but
really didn't codify it at all
the way that i have um recently and i'm
not trying to like
give myself props or anything but it you
know that he has like a mind
he wrote the mindset down he was an
innovator in that area and it's awesome
but
not i don't really see that many people
have a system
for this and if everybody had even like
one tenth of the systems that we created
that are really easy for this
people would have people find it much
easier to find jobs and the niches that
they like people would be able to make
life decisions better they would have
stronger friendships which means they're
going to be healthier and live longer
like
that is a gift to anybody who decides to
put in five minutes a day and do it it's
like yeah
you know i almost feel like i innovated
on the friggin
sit-up or something like it's so
fundamental and yet
it works you know you really do it i
have to say you know for those of you
who might listen to jordan does he
actually do this
so the reason that i actually ended up
eventually getting on the bot is
eventually you sent me a text or an
email like responded to an email that i
wrote
a year ago or whatever like can you
please get your crap together keating
and
then submit this you know i'd still like
to have you in the house like holy crap
because i'd kind of given up
no i didn't hear from you and i've got
enough stuff going on but you go through
your text messages as part of
the networking course the other thing
that's like so innovative jordan i just
love like
use this tool that's used by you know i
don't want to say the slimiest people no
because some of my best friends and
relatives are realtors but
but use a tool that's really pioneered
or invented for real estate agents i'm
like what the hell is he talking about
and it's a way to you know manage
relationships which sounds really like
transactional in itself
but it's beautiful because it reminds me
like oh yeah not like i'm gonna forget
to call my mom every every night or
whatever
but it reminds me wow i haven't talked
to that person at the funding agency
who said that they loved you know my
youtube video and maybe i can you know
just just send
i'm thinking of you and and she'll be
just pleased to hear it
and it'll give me a reminder because i'm
not that smart and i can remember
everything so
i do want to thank you for that and
these innovative tactics tricks and
techniques so that's six minute
networking because five minute
networking was taken it's taken yeah but
but it's a brilliant scheme and i think
it's useful for all
uh all disciplines as including
scientists because as i said the reality
is that it's 80 percent you're how you
network
and in your soft skills next question uh
jordan
comes from the movie 2001 which is based
on the book 2001
uh by sir arthur c clarke who is the
namesake of our center here in san diego
and you remember if you i've assumed
you've seen the movie or you know some
of the exact
i'm sorry dave i can't do that yes
exactly oh the opening scene and
throughout the movie
version that kubrick did there are these
monoliths or these kind of like huge
objects on the plains of africa three
million years ago that some primates
find and then
they astronauts find them on the moon
and it's sort of meant to be like a time
capsule or something placed by an
ancient civilization
perhaps as a warning perhaps as as as an
aphorism or
advice or whatever to human beings that
they will discover when they are
technologically advanced enough to
discover it perhaps in the case of going
to the moon
you know we couldn't see this monolith
on the moon until we went to the moon
and we had technology to go to the moon
at least as this uh as the book and the
movie are portraying it
i want to ask you if you had a
billion-year time capsule that was going
to encapsulate
everything that you know human beings or
everything that's important to you that
you want
to be kind of the time capsule that
represents earth
to last for a future version of earth or
an alien civilization to discover
what would you put in the monolith on
the monolith
you know a floppy disk what would you do
with that monolith
if you had that opportunity
wow jeez this is for like a future
civilization to discover
are they they're more technologically
advanced than we are or they're just
starting over and they happen to find
this
no well yeah they'll happen to find it
you know you'll put it there you're
guaranteed this thing is going to last
for
for a billion years actually i had
andrewian on my show
and she was the wife of the late great
carl sagan again a picture of him
and she actually put her brain waves and
music and sentences
on a golden disc attached to the voyager
spacecraft
which will go out into the deep reaches
of interstellar space for
five billion years she says um so she
had this time capsule and that was what
she put on in her brain waves
and so i guess i'm asking yes somebody
will find it someday you don't know who
what would you put on it as a token of
the existence of
of you of human kind of uh your greatest
messages on uh that there are to ask or
i don't have any kind of deep answer to
that
not even anything i say is gonna be even
beyond detroit like
oh i put some advice on like who the
hell wants to hear from me
yeah i think at best we can be like
don't come to this planet we are busy
ruining it and we're probably just gonna
have people
shoot you if you land here just i've had
astrophysicists say
basically that yeah warning do not enter
yeah like wait another couple of hundred
thousand years and either we'll all be
dead or we'll have figured it out by now
or we'll have robot overlords that are
like
we don't let the humans do anything
they're a bunch of idiots yeah we took
those powers away and gave them to uh
elon musk
all right the last one hopefully it's a
little bit easier also relates to
uh sir arthur c clarke and it's actually
the reason for the name behind this
podcast into the impossible
is arthur's uh third law his first law
is the only way to
uh there's uh sorry the um
uh oh man why am i blanking on this uh
i'm going to say a second law let me say
a second law first the second law is
that for every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert his third law
is the only way to discover what is
possible is to venture beyond the limits
of the possible
into the impossible and i want to ask
you of all the setbacks and failures and
recoveries etc
that you've gone through what things
seemed impossible to you
as a younger person maybe in your 20s
maybe in your 30s
that now seems possible because you went
ahead and did it
oh i mean i never thought i could start
my own business
and i accidentally almost i should say
almost accidentally started my own
business you know with the show here
with the jordan harbinger show
but i always thought business owners
were either people that had like
some sort of specialized education or
had or they started a restaurant or
something like that i never really
understood
how it always was like this other class
of person that could own a business
you know it wasn't me it wasn't what our
family did
it didn't make sense i was just gonna
get a job i would never actually
own anything i'd never actually be like
the boss of anything or control
something and
then i started doing what i really
enjoyed and i was like oh you can carve
your own path i mean talk about
something that is just not
taught to kids in the united states
surprisingly
right like we're this land of free
thinkers and we're like everybody do
their own thing
and like this is you know don't let
listen to the man and then it's like oh
but just kidding
not you though you should listen to the
man and you should not do your own thing
you should be a good little worker bee
so i was a good student and when you're
a good student you are taught to
try not to think for yourself just work
really hard for someone else
and i'm like that is such a sucker's
play
you know like starting your own business
are all the time
it's weird because you get out of school
and they're like be a good employee
during the whole time you're in school
then you get out of school
and then suddenly you look at what the
government wants you to do and it's like
oh no we want tax structures for
business owners we want people to start
businesses we encourage small business
ownership
we really want people to start and be
productive members of the economy and
it's like what was the last 12 years of
[ __ ] you gave me about like be a
good worker be show up at the bell quit
at the bell
right you know what was that all that
about on time is late right yeah
on top of this and it's kind of like oh
well you know that works for some people
so you you just really want the most
stubborn
people who've failed for the last 12
years and whose parents have like all
but given up on them
those are the people you want to start
businesses you don't want all the smart
people that are like
have tons of potential you want to lock
those people in a room and have them
like doing financial accounting for
a fortune 500 company what the hell's
going on here what's wrong with you
wow jordan well i want to thank you so
much i'm sorry i kept you over i know
it's a busy time for you i just want you
to know how much gratitude i have for
you and everything that you do you've
been inside my
ears for over a decade i appreciate that
watch
deliver so much value as they say in the
industry
but but you're really a role model for
people young and old
and i want you to keep doing what you're
doing and have the greatest success
with the other two jays in your life and
i wish you a wonderful weekend i thank
you
so much for being on the show jordan
thanks for having me on man we'll talk
soon
[Music]
awesome
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.gov
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
[Music]
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division
of physical sciences at the university
of california san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco